fortbewegungsmittels mallow
wahrscheinlich sehr unabhängig und und
mein eigener chef zu
ich glaube dass jetzt wirklich nicht
freiheits tun
sie sind nicht einfach paketboten sie
stehen für eine alternative
lebenshaltung velokuriere sind
idealisten die gegen den strom fahren
ganz individuell wie ihre vorlieben
tourismus studiert sachen betreuung und
hat dort studiert die kaufmännische
lehre gemacht ich bin nur freischaffend
als künstler
für sie ist es nicht ein beruf es ist
eine mission
sowohl nämlich und identifiziere sich
viel mehr als ein job es ist persönlich
am nachmittag auszutragen
[Musik]
wir sind sicher noch ein plus für die
zeit mit begann zur fortbewegung
wir sind bundesweit mit dem thema
nachhaltigkeit manfred pretscher mal die
unwahrheit oder junge liegt sicher nicht
bringen weil ich bereit zu den gegner
stundenlohn relativ aus stangen die
arbeit zu machen bieten wir nun ein herr
praktikanten stinken fiebig und trotzdem
macht es gern der velokurier wurde war
für mich ein frisches video vermittelt
statement
[Musik]
damals wie ein eimer mit dem wellengang
auf die tour von der bus hoch präzise
automatische nation
das auto erst mal wichtig sie quasi
selbst verstanden ist und wirklich
flüsse so durch die staaten durch den
verkehr
die schönste tag im vom wähler sind die
ivo muser von floh er in die weiten wege
glücklich ist und worauf sie sich vom
meldung
[Musik]
das ist weder matrix und es ist ein
zustand nicht vermisst also eine
verlängerte ferien oder so ist eine
schöne zustand einfach wie man schicke
damit mit dem velo es menschlich
datenverkehr
das tempo im moment lebensmuster sie und
meine zuschnitte gedanken
[Musik]
die velokuriere wissenschaft winterthur
ist fast eine familie
das tröstet über den lohn knapp am
existenzminimum hinweg sie teilen sich
das essen und die arbeit vor dem
computer ihre freiheit erkaufen sie sich
mit einem minimalistischen lebensstil
aber ich sagen so lebensumstände dass
mir dass er so bald ich wohne geschaut
sehr günstig dort setzte die ich teile
mir das internet mit mir nach
das auto sitzt mit so vielen nur von
etwas können sie nicht genug kriegen von
velos sauber gefahren sind es noch 46
zwischen 20
mit der launische rango finde ich sehr
schön mit kollege linie werkstatt und
noch immer wieder mal velos zu weit
noch waren die velokuriere den zwängen
der bürgerlichen existenz davon
doch die tage der freiheit sind gezählt
das wissen sie wer weiß ja nie was mit
dem körper passiert oder wie viel das
man blieb will ich wirklich dann aber
auch genannten standorten wir haben wir
morgen schon klären
denn irgendwann auch denke ich sie schon
ein to five job